bryn wrote in saying have ads ever
convinced you to buy anything all right
I want to dig into this most people I
speak to about advertising say I'm
impervious to advertising ads have never
convinced me to buy anything and to that
I would say the fact that you can't
specifically identify items or services
you've bought because of advertising
number one doesn't disprove disprove
that advertising works and number two
it's almost proof that it does because
when you don't people make buying
decisions all the time unless you
literally buy nothing you are making
conscious decisions or unconscious
decisions in some cases about which
product or service to buy in which
product service not to buy the fact that
you don't think advertising has affected
you if you're sort of a normal person
who lives in the world means that
advertising is really effective because
you believe that those were completely
your own decisions and they were
influenced by either what you heard from
ads or what you heard from friends based
on what they heard from ad so I I
believe that although I can't tell you
specifically what I've purchased based
on advertising there's no doubt that
advertising has an effect on me it has
an effect on you right but I can't say
that I was directly influenced by an ad
to purchase anything either i have no
idea really what i can tell you is that
adds anger me mmm it doesn't matter what
they are where i'm seeing them uh the
the only time i'm okay with any type of
advertisement is if i find that it's
really funny if uh otherwise I I am I am
angered and annoyed by any and every
advertisement I see and I'd like to
think that uh because of that I'm not
directly influenced by ads to to buy
things Jason I think that sometimes it's
easy for people to say I see an
infomercial for like the stair master
clenched whatever new advertising but
you know but exercise product and I'm
just never gonna buy I mean that ad was
not effective on me and I think that
sometimes people get mixed up by that
and don't realize that all the time even
at the grocery store in so many places
you're always making these decisions
that have in some way been influenced by
maybe not a specific ad but these sort
of general
fairness campaigns where because over
time you're more aware of one product
over another when it's time for you to
make a buying decision you might feel
like you're naturally going to it but
there's really nothing natural about it
you've been influenced by advertising
yet these people that say they've never
been influenced by advertising i would
ask suitable your nose with i imagine
they would say Kleenex soda you know
same thing would you clean your ears
with they'd probably say a q-tip and
those are brands right yeah instead and
band-aid is another example we're
talking about adhesive bandages but it's
become so part of the uh sort of lexicon
that people now call them by the
effective brand name which is bandaid in
that particular case uh yeah so I have a
hard time believing that unless you are
living a very unusually isolated type of
life you are being influenced by
advertising and the fact that you might
not identify specific products is
probably only supporting evidence of
that